confidence is the willingness to try my
character my personality a lot of that
came from martial art it's no doubt in
my mind you should really go to our time
at home one day and volunteer and just
talk to them it won't make you want to
do every minute your life
what's that belief nation it seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's live your
best believe life and learn five tricks
you can develop to have unstoppable
confidence also if you want to know what
Tony Robbins Mel Robbins Gary Vee and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the fact that
human beings our strongest drive is the
need to stay consistent with how we
define ourselves I know that everybody's
problem comes down to one pattern you're
repeating that you can't see the reason
people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take action with Mel Robbins I've
always been very scared and lack of
confidence and thought that I was never
good enough like some of my partners
hold on who can relate to that
struggling with lack of confidence not
good enough all the research around
confidence points to something we've all
bought into a lie we've bought into a
lie that confidence is belief in self
and so when you're in a situation which
is normal where you don't believe in
yourself you're like oh my god I have no
confidence the truth is and I want you
to walk out of here with a new
definition of confidence confidence is
the willingness to try because when you
try and you take action what happens and
what's happened for France is that when
she sees herself taking action what
happens is she sees herself being the
kind of person that takes action so she
has evidence that she can rely on
herself and that action is what builds
confidence it doesn't start with belief
the real way the real way for most of us
is not to wait to believe but to push
ourself to act and through the action
you will build the belief rule number
two become someone else with Tony
Robbins all of us have kind of an
identity for ourselves a way of defining
ourselves and human beings don't usually
stray from that so if you consider
yourself to be a conservative person or
a shy person I know the way you move to
some extent I know the facial
expressions the gestures that I use your
body and it's all consistent with the
fact that human beings our strongest
Drive is the need to stay consistent
with how we define ourselves if your
self definition is I'm a situation where
I'm kind of what was already used
shy-shy then you're gonna find a way to
get to a place where you kind of cower
back
that's this thing you could do to change
your experience would be to create a new
little thing of simple thing like erase
the meaning I'm shy go erase that's a BS
story BS meaning belief system that's
just a story and if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe it you act like it
when you cook calling yourself shy you
believe you have always been shot up
until this moment do something that's
completely outside what you would
normally do something become somebody
else decide who's the most playful
passionate outrageous fun person you
know and behave like them for two or
three days just push yourself to behave
like that here's what's happened you'll
be shocked and you'll be weird you'll be
different you'll feel uncomfortable but
after a while you'll get reinforced it's
like if you get a nice haircut you make
a change in way you look people
compliment you you'll get some
compliments and those compliments will
make you want to use those other parts
yourself rule number three keep the
promises you made to you with Edie mine
let the key to self confidence is really
simple and it is this is absolutely I've
trained hundreds of thousands of people
I've spoken to millions of people around
the world I could tell you this the
self-confident people I know whether
they are athletes school teachers
mechanics parents stay-at-home moms you
name it they have a pattern of keeping
promises they make to themselves the
groundwork of beginning to build
self-confidence is to begin to keep the
promises you make to you and that's why
it's important to begin to even make
small promise you're gonna get up at a
certain time in the morning not only do
it but then give yourself credit say I
did what I said I was gonna do if it's
in your diet or your fitness don't just
eat the healthy foods go I'm doing what
I said I was going to do you begin to
build this reputation if you're
constantly being influenced and moved by
what other people think about you it
means there's a deficiency and what you
think about you and so the key is not
some you know and so esoteric like
belief system it's a pattern of keeping
the promises that you make to you that's
the groundwork of self-confidence for
sure and it is a pattern when I meet
people that lack confidence I think let
me serve you let's begin to keep the
promises you make to you you're so
worried about there's this addiction to
other people's approval in the world
right it's the greatest the greatest
addiction today it used to be drugs
before that it was alcohol there's all
these addictions sex addictions whatever
the
one addiction in the world today is the
addiction to other people's approval and
that's because we don't approve of
ourselves we or we don't feel a spirit a
universe a God that we believe in that
approves of us and so my confidence
comes from both my faith and him the
fact that I keep promises I make to
myself that's the groundwork of all
confidence wheel number four do martial
arts with Dan lock so what's getting
beat up in school is getting bully and I
was getting beat up like bully not
always physical if I got beat up
multiple times and I was just sick and
tired of it so one night I was watching
cable TV was flipping through the
channel and I saw this guy this man and
the movie was we turn up the dragon by
Bruce Lee he was doing nunchuck and and
kicking everyone's ass and at the end
and fought with Chuck Norris and then
beat Chuck Norris and I was like all my
god I I found my hero from that moment
you know I want to be like Bruce Lee I
want to learn martial arts so back then
near my house there was a karate school
kind of like Taekwondo school and I
immediately I joined a class and I was
taking the class I was practicing I was
stretching I was practicing my stuff
every day I was obsessed I mean I would
practice three four hours every day
because I was so skinny I was 105 pounds
but then I would do my push up and
workout and and started gaining little
bit of little bit of muscles so after I
was training for about six months or so
now if you if you ever done any martial
art you know after you practice martial
art you develop this natural self
confidence not cockiness but you develop
this natural self-confidence so what's
walking around our mind I was no longer
like this more like okay right you you
you know you can you know you could kind
of take care of yourself so I was doing
that and I guess maybe always have a
teachers heart other kids would started
asking me all what are you doing I would
show them different move and as I was
showing them different move all the kids
would see it oh this is cool like what
are you doing I said well you know
Chinese Kung Fu min right so I was
showing them different things right
there up upstairs every single lunch I
would either for about five ten minutes
in a sandwich the rest of the lunch
was teaching I was teaching them martial
art right here right there at their
second floor every single day and I
loved it
not because I was teaching them how to
hurt people or even how to defend
themselves but I noticed when the kids
that was teaching even my mantra wasn't
particularly that good back then I could
see them just forming that they become
just more more confident and they become
a better version of themselves and I
love seeing people just transformed like
that that's why I owe a lot of what I
have today my my character and my
personality a lot of that came from
martial art it's no doubt in my mind as
a businessman as an entrepreneur as a
husband a lot of philosophies I learned
from martial art and rule number five
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is let regret drive you with Gary
Vaynerchuk you should really go to our
tyrant home one day and volunteer just
talk to them it won't make you wanna do
every minute in your life because when
you're 90 and you're not mobile and
you're tired and it's over you can't do
it you can't do it you can't build that
company wanted you can't spend that time
with your kids
it's regret and it's Rives how old are
you time it's a it's a balance of regret
and patience like you can go hard of fun
for three years do nothing right wake up
and be young as the amount of people who
are watching this right now maybe even
in this room that are sad men and women
that they didn't go for it
and didn't make the move and didn't try
that regret is a hell of a lot longer
and more painful and more drawn out than
the instant rejection of going for it
it's just the way it is like even if you
think of random dumb stuff like not
asking out that person in high school or
so there's stuff lingers it's the stuff
that you don't do that bothers you and
so for the purebred entrepreneurs in
here that haven't decided to make that
leap or take that at bat
I implore you to do so right away
because this window closes - now I've
got a really special bonus clip with
Robin Sharma and how to study the
alchemy that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business answer these three
questions and if you're feeling bold
leave your replies in the comments below
here we go question number one what
regret can you use right now to drive
you number two what promise did you make
to yourself that you need to keep and
number three who do you need to become
to accomplish your goals study the
alchemy now here's what I mean by that
what happens to most people in life
especially the victims is they reach a
part of their life you know a difficult
time and they call it failure I mean
even just labeling a setback as a
failure trigger something into your
mindset to release cortisol the fear
hormone which blocks your best
performance and so you want to see
yourself and you want to study the
alchemy which is where other people are
seeing a failure or setback or even a
little problem you want to look for the
gold you want to train your brain so you
have a dominant belief it just becomes
automatic because you've practiced it so
much where when someone says there's a
problem or there's a wall or there's a
failure you literally see the alchemy to
turn the lead into gold maybe you're
going through a divorce maybe you're
going through an illness a lot of people
who watch this podcasts are going
through difficulties or outright
tragedies but you want to practice
seeing the setback or the dark time as
fuel to leverage your growth and so on
this first point about study the alchemy
no matter what you're going through in
your life whether it's a large
difficulty or a small setback you want
to ask yourself how can I use what I'm
going
through as fuel for my growth you want
to ask yourself what is the gorgeous
opportunity hidden inside this so-called
problem I mean and if you look at the
mass of humanity they really train their
brains to focus on problems right the
hit a wall and they just because of
their belief system they don't know it
because most people are not really that
aware of their belief systems so they
blame it on the world they blame it on
the supplier they blame it on the
teammate they blame it on their husband
or wife they blame it on their childhood
versus understanding our daily
performance reflects our deepest beliefs
and so if you are experiencing some kind
of a setback whether its large or tiny
you want to train your brain to see the
treasure within the led raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion and
not one drop of our self-worth depends
on your it's suppose to mean
if you want to know the 20 best pieces
of advice that every aspiring
entrepreneur needs to hear check out the
video right next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there and to work on the
alignment of your personality